an East Tennessee middle school student
is speaking out to us after an emotional
Facebook video where he talks about
being bullied in this widely shared
video Keaton Jones explains how fellow
students poured milk on him and stuffed
food and his clothes now his mother's
addressing the backlash on social media
over some other posts which show her and
her son with Confederate flags
mark Strassmann reports from
maynardville Tennessee had enough love
that they had said that some rules I
would to beat me up in lunch so I
touched him my mom and I said what do I
do here whose idea was it to make Keaton
Jones says he has been targeted by five
fellow middle schoolers you never
complained to a teacher you never
complain to a principal oh because I was
afraid that they would for sure attack
he became more and more agitated he
didn't wanna go back to school Kim Jones
the 11-year olds mother was behind the
camera and posted the video to her
Facebook what do you think of the
world's reaction I knew that it could be
great and I knew that it could be awful
and it has been the spotlight on Keaton
also cast attention on to Kim's prior
social media posts including this one
where she's holding a confederate flag a
symbol of pride for some and racism for
others her daughter's Twitter also
contained a family photo with a
confederate flag the only two about the
only two photos on my entire planet that
I'm anywhere near a Confederate flag it
was ironic it was funny didn't have
anything to do was no racist intent no
no absolutely not
absurd I spent most of my life being
bullied and and judged because I wasn't
racist thanks to the video Keaton Jones
went from a bullied middle schooler to a
boy with friends around the world
did the video make you feel better made
me felt like I had accomplished
something real something that could
actually change the world
this is Keaton's middle school which
plans to hold an anti-bullying assembly
on Monday the Union County school board
here told us they do not and will not
tolerate bullying but Keaton told us he
doesn't plan to go back to school until
January after the winter break Nora all
right mark thank you he should be able
to go back to school and they should
provide the support that he needs to go
back to school it's important to stay
focused I think too on the issue of
bullying that's what I keep saying Nora
you know there's a lot of controversy
and certainly when you look on social
media where the mothers being criticized
about the Confederate flag and her
motives for putting up the video trying
to get money from the family there's all
sorts of rumors and speculation out
there but I agree with you stay focused
on this little boy he was clearly hurt
he was clearly bullied and that's what
I'm that's what I keep taking in that
you know that boy touched a lot it my
heart hurt when I watched that and I
think a lot of people feel that way yeah
but do you hear him say he feels like he
changed the world that's he did that's
better for him 20 million people looked
at that video in over 48 hours and it
made an impact attend